qu'on va pouvoir peut-être offrir 50
mille euros un téléspectateur qui va
partager avec les hôpitaux de paris et
de france et une somme incroyable
on va jouer aux boîtes 15 boiboite qui
sont là ce qui va jouer avec nous il ya
une candidate qui va jouer avec nous et
elle va jouer en duo avec quelqu'un que
j'adore qui est pour moi vraiment la
plus grande révélation de ces cinq
dernières années on va pas se mentir
elle fait un énorme carton elle a eu
elle a été primée aux olympiens awards
c'est l'humoriste de l'année je vous le
dis je la dore camille lellouche est
avec nous ça va ma camille d'amour c'est
trop mignon merci de m'accueillir comme
ça combien sont très bons donc tu sois
je suis très content que tu sois là ma
chérie elle est drôle si elle chante
elle danse elle fait kiffer elle fait
des personnages tu sais qu'on vaut aux
haut franchement c'est sur un site assez
incroyable je peux rester des journées
entières et tout le monde dès que je
vois quelques à regarder une vidéo sur
un stade c'est une vidéo de camille
lelouch c'est un truc de ouf
tu es là michel drucker d'instagram sur
ma liste est donc le meilleur des
hystériques deux singles et savants de
macamic chérie tu es chez toi tu es
convenait très bien tu en es tu kartonn
et ma chérie tu vas jouer pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
et tu vas peut-être faire gagner sur
peut-être pouvoir partager la somme de
50 mille euros c'est les bois boîte
c'est une somme exceptionnelle et tu vas
jouer avec un jeune homme qui est très
mignon très beau gosse on ya eu celui ci
l'a comment comment tu est intitulé mon
chéri messaoud salut messaoud hassi
messaoud et j'aime bien messaoud je suis
sûr et certain que lui il a fait des
études douvres le voile sur la tête de
ma mère lui doit normalement je te
repères en début d'année je me macau
tétouan toute l'année
c'est sûr et certain luis frère mais ça
vous ferait il est frais il prend que tu
vois tu sais qu'il travaille bien
ensemble et avec ne m'en parle ton
équipe canada mon message à vous faire
[ __ ] mais ça va super et tu vas jouer
avec camille lellouche salut aimé ça ou
tu fais quoi dans la vie
moi je travaille pour une organisation
de sécurité sociale située dans le
valais ouais ça se passe comme tu veux
ça fait quoi comme études tu as fait
quoi comme étude ne mens pas je sais que
je sais que tu es fort très t.abh signé
c'est comment tu habilles et la table a
tenu qu'on met normalement quand on fait
la photo de classe
tu sais le la veille la prof elle dit
attention de contrat le club d'accord
kevin szalai ces aspects la botte à
millas tâtonner dans le menton photos
classées très bien des cas sans bobo ça
fait quoi son habitude en fait j'ai
commencé d'administration d'accor est
chiant je te reconnais pas là mais c'est
ce qu'on vous dit pas c'est pas toi là
tu le donnes un jour là normalement il y
à l'époque de messaoud qui l'on regarde
comme ça
non il a complètement pété une durite
quoi tu vois autant il était non mais
messaoud c'était vraiment un mec sur qui
tout est compté et la messaoud a pété un
câble avec le compliment il en a plus
rien à [ __ ] de rien comme ça où tu
ressens c'est basé mon chéri a joué bien
franchement être d'anniversaire pour les
10 ans un amour ma chérie
j'étais là quand la première moi j'ai
très bien c'était vraiment un truc si à
l'époque bon on va rester les démissions
de l'école du pij s'était pas troisièmes
sont jouables c'est vrai quand j'ai vu
trois missions jeudi mais là encore une
merde à la télé c'était pas possible
d'annoncer que tu as assisté à ma
première et c'est super que tu assistes
à la dernière de matthieu delormeau ce
soir allez les chéris on va jouer avec
les boiboite les boiboite regarder ce
qu'il ya à gagner aujourd'hui dans les
bois boîte il y as jusqu'à 50000 euros à
gagner
il y a dans les boîtes aujourd'hui il ya
quinze boîte il ya une équerre un cube à
1,9 pour pessah ça peut servir
un couple ongles des piles une machine à
café un casque audio un smartphone un
dinar tunisien puis ensuite ya les
sommes 100 euros 500 euros 1000 euros
5000 euros dix mille euros et 50000
euros
peut-être des hôpitaux de paris pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france et
pour messaoud puisque vous partagerez la
somme on va démarrer à jouer avec
camille lellouche et messaoud est ce que
vous voulez déjà
gardez moi tu messaoud est ce que tu
veux garder une boîte de côté tout de
suite à faire taire les gens une fois
confiance à gagny camille quelle boîte
tu choisis entre la première et la 15e à
la 5e
la cinquième donc la cinquième boîte
c'est isabelle morini-bosc en plus
regardées qui a dessiné dessus kéké
voilà qui est symbolisé par un cinquième
5ème boîte ça sera votre boîte après
vous pourrez peut-être l'échangé que ces
tirs est ce que vous voulez et déminer
tout de suite une boîte voulait éliminer
tout de suite une boîte ou pas allez on
élimine une boîte messaoud élimine
d'accord allez on y va s'agace boîte ok
ok habache éliminant la lune la une la
une c'est benjamin castaldi dans la
boîte numéro une
messaoud tu à éliminer pour camille est
pour toi non
c'était une boîte pas mal parce que tu
as éliminé meilleur 500 à nice 500 euros
c'était pas mal du tout 500 euros et 500
euros
c'est terminé messaoud et quatre cas
mais est ce que tu veux choisir une
boîte au bâton moi ce que tu veux
éliminer une boîte way éliminer une
boîte
ouais la rochelle quality jean j'élimine
la deux la de plus la boîte numéro 2 la
boîte numérique 2 c'est valérie bene
02 camille lellouche ma chérie tu as de
la chance dans la vie
ça va dans la vie mais en jeu au jeu
malheureusement n'a pas de chance parce
que je te refais s'il ya un contrôle de
géométrie tu vas être mal sans équerre
très bien venu miner caire très bonne
boîte très bonne boîte choisi par camilo
nous choque alors qu'hamid messaoud
allez on élimine encore une boîte on
élimine trois boîtes par trois boîtes à
laisser la dernière a éliminé avant la
proposition semblable à ta mère des
larmes et sa route on va dire l'asti 108
et l'a11
non d'abord la puce d'amour tout ça
c'est la troisième boîte que vous avez
éliminé les seconds non mais tu es
d'accord avec moi quand même sa polique
et les vélos vélos à 10 mois quelle
boîte à jambes en ut on prend deux noms
mais voilà attendent un symbole il
assiste sans qu'on a pris la 6 messaoud
encore éliminé deux sont éliminés sont
bas c'est pas grave ça soyons pas 600
euros 600 euros si si il y avait un look
blanche à notre banquier qui veut vous
faire une proposition
merzouk blanchard pour l'instant le cami
lellouche et messaoud ont éliminé la
boîte à 500 euros la boîte à son héros
et les quais dans un instant
je vous le dis on va revenir très très
très très vite on va revenir très vite
et dans un instant on saura combien
camille lellouche et messaoud vont
gagner et on aura la proposition du
banquier je vous rappelle qu'il est
encore la boîte à 50000 euros à tout de
suite mes petits chéris pour les mois
boite à toutes les beautés
merci d'être avec nous il est 19 heures
48 on est en direct sur ces mythes et
les cherry on joue au jeu des bois boîte
et il ya jusqu'à 58 euros à se partager
entre messaoud et les hôpitaux de paris
et de france représentée par camille
lellouche qui a voulu jouer pour eux
qu'ils voulaient jouer pour la bonne
cause ma camille lellouche que j'ai
merci camille d'être avec nous les
chéris si vous nous rejoignez on est en
direct et on va revoir les sommes qui
ont été éliminés il y a un instant il y
avait bien sûr une boîte à 50000 euros
il ya une boîte à 10000 euros toujours
une boîte à 5000 euros une boîte à 1000
et vous avez perdu
la boîte à 500 la boîte à sons et une
équerre c'était la boîte choisi sait pas
à quel point je me désolidarise moins
pour l'instant
pour l'instant ça va pour l'instant ça
vole pas camille stopper merzoug
blanchard qu'est notre banquier enchanté
à granby c'est un grand banquier
d'affaires ensemble bien sûr il était
sachez qu'il était c'est un grand trait
de leur puisqu'il était trader orientale
pendant des années merzouk enchanté je
représente la tp banques alors alors je
vous propose monsieur messaoud
ouais il un deal à vous proposer
pourquoi n'aviez pas plus loin j'ai
transpiré
je vous propose de vous racheter votre
boîte
tenez vous bien et vu nouveaux habits
vous n'allez pas dire non 400 euros non
400 euros pour la boîte camille claud
michaud supplie taffetas de deux fois
rage moi j'en ai pas encore jusque là
que tu te plais bien en lagarde la 5
moi je garde le garde sur la vie de kent
pour les palmiers unique son garde vous
refuser la proposition on veut notre
traders orientale mais aussi notre très
dense de talent bien sûr spécialiste en
makrouds et autre manie coty merci merci
ou qui reviendra tout à leur merci vous
avez toujours choisi votre boîte et la
boîte numéro 5
les chéris j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui m'apaise avec
cette musique sur la tête de ma mère
les chéris vous à l'éliminer maintenant
une nouvelle boîte
camille je t'écoute monsieur bien et
vite
tu es limite la boîte numéro 8 c'est
raymond raymond notre raymond qui est
sur la boîte
rêvons regarder même sur la boîte
il a l'air en dépression le pauvre on
embrasse fort révèle espère qu'on pourra
l'entendre un jour en duplex camilo
louche tout à l'heure tu à éliminer les
caire tu avais choisi une boîte
exceptionnelle qu'a minima chien
apparemment tu as la main puisque tu as
des mines la machine à café
c'est une bonne boîte j'ai des mines et
bravo à vous car il reste toujours la
boîte à 56 millions douaniers la boîte a
dit même là est-ce qu'on peut revoir
l'échelle de gains souplet il reste
encore la boîte à 50000 si vous nous
rejoignez la boîte à 10000 la boîte à
5000 la boîte à bulles je rappelle qu'on
joue pour messaoud qui est un
téléspectateur et aussi pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
qu'il veut éliminer la prochaine boîte
les saoud ou camus d'amis je te fais
confiance
tammy je te fais confiance à fond à fond
à fond moi j'ai eu deux échecs d'union
mais super six mois et l'instant les
justices itude energy star joue bien
l'année
j'élimine l'a9 l'a9 trembler tous et la
nasse j'ai déjà eu deux échecs ses choix
franchement c'est pourquoi est elle
annoncée les hôpitaux aussi et surtout
patent sur le mans parce que là on va
voir quelle boîte s à éliminer quelqu'un
stable si tu penses bien doute c'est moi
petit plus dans le cas de cyril camus
est ce que tu me vois ça y est ce que tu
me vois là et là tu en voilà non hélas
hélas là tu me voilà allez vous y verrez
tous là est ce que tu me vois oui oui
est-ce que tu m'entends oui est-ce que
tu m'entends est alors merci
un petit hommage jeter qui déjà ça ah
ouais t'es les tragédies nombre mais on
en croit ce qu'on va vivre
est ce qu'on va vivre une tragédie avec
cette boîte que tu limite est ce que tu
a éliminé il 50000 euros
non non cali pour l'instant tu fait un
sans faute ma chérie et quoi et bien à
camille le smartphone
foot c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave le smartphone je c pas
grave pour l'instant camille est
exceptionnel il reste la boîte à 50000
euros la boîte à 10000 euros il reste la
boîte à 5000 ont également et amis
n'auront pour l'instant vous avez vous
avez des quatre plus grosses boîtes
encore cali j'ai une question là je dois
éliminer un
ouais ouais mais si je gagnais environ
90 me suis peut-être gagner celle de dix
milles derrière
mais ça fait 60 non mais non tu n'as
qu'une boîte m'achète une boîte à idées
moi je l'écrirai tut échos comme quoi je
t'explique mcsherry oui tu as ta boîte
numéro 5
c'est la boîte que tu as choisi là tu
fais que d'éliminer des boîtes d'accord
ok alors là on l'a donc tu as tord à la
somme que tu as dans la 5
oui donc pour l'instant à éliminer des
bonnes boîtes à les éliminer une boîte
encore là cette belle fête
on y croit et monique hoquet la secte
c'est jean michel merle à 7
donc il joue élimine la boîte numéro 7
et après on aura une nouvelle
proposition de notre banque émerge
blanchard à l'issue richesse vous avez
éliminé pour l'instant cinq boîtes
camille pour l'instant a fait vraiment
un sans-faute exceptionnel je rappelle
que vous jouez au messaoud et pour les
hôpitaux de paris et de france vous
aurez une somme à vous partager plus
assez important 36 camille oui camille
tu fait un sans faute pour l'instant tu
attendais lesquels tu a éliminé le
smartphone je peux voir l'échelle de
l'échelle souples et légers dégâts tu es
éliminé également tué diminuer la
machine à café où il a tué des mines m
pour l'instant trois boîtes
vous avez fait un parcours exceptionnel
il vous reste encore la boîte à 1000 la
boîte à 5000 la boîte à 10000 la boîte à
50000 euros je vous rappelle qu'on joue
pour messaoud et pour les hôpitaux de
paris et de france
les housses blanches à notre traders
orientale il était charcutier trader
pendant des années deuxième ronde et la
mort ils vendaient de la mortadelle et
du saucisson sur les marchés boursiers
au père dodu ils travaillent avec nous
justement donc j'ai la proposition
suivante à lézignan réfléchissez bien
monsieur verdoux non merzouk c'est moi
messaoud
je suis là mais alors je voudrais 7
votre boîte
écoutez moi bien pour 1200 euros
net 1200 c'est une belle somme souvenir
sachant qu'il vous reste encore la boîte
à 1000 la boîte à 5000 la boîte à 10000
la boîte à 50 milles et à divertir les
200 euros
1200 euros ce qui ferait 600 euros pour
messaoud et 600 euros pour les hôpitaux
de paris hôpitaux de france spécial chez
vous sachez que dans la vie il faut
savoir prendre ce qui est tu skies est
là pour iphone est quand même score il
reste encore beaucoup de très très
grosses boîtes
voilà c'est ça qu'il soit repensé
message est bien à moi personnellement
je pense que je vais refuser cette
proposition pour monsieur berges ou chat
sms maintiennent merci merci merci merci
merci
blanchard il continue vous avez pour
l'instant choisi la boîte numéro 5
on élimine les autres boîtes c'est parti
on est limité on élimine une nouvelle
boîte je vous rappelle qu'ils peuvent
gagner jusqu'à 50000 aux rousses et les
bois boîte de baba alexis à les éliminer
allez qu'il bessaoud nouvelle boîte moi
je les scanne i je laisse camille moi
j'ai eu deux échecs à l'ail trois
victoires jollès qu'à nice est mort je
moi je
vas-y maqam aller l'a12 [ __ ] j'ai très
peur la seconde face aux la dénonciation
de la douche avec notre ami jean luc
lemoine sur la boîte j'espère qu'on va
gagner
rousseau j'espère bien c'est important
pour les hôpitaux
elle est là allez allez allez
[Musique]
je vois pas s'il va au non non non
maintenant la mie câline camille camille
non mais camille tu sais pourquoi je dis
oh non parce que je sais que tu en
prends soin de toi et que tu viens de
perdre le couple ongles camille
lellouche qui est exceptionnel pour
l'instant sachets et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs je ne sais pas ce qu'il
ya dans les boîtes je n'ai pas voulu
savoir
j'ai pas voulu savoir qu'amy titre est
en forme et il vous reste encore à
calmer mais ça ou de la boîte a mis la
boîte à 5 me la boîte à 10000 la boîte à
50000 à les éliminer une nouvelle boîte
l'a13 l'a13 la boîte avec notre ami doc
gynéco il est ce qu'on embrasse fort il
rester en f1 team à des piles à la voie
aux vacances qui reste on va voir ce qui
reste regardez pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoignent
regardez ce qui reste comme boîte ils
peuvent gagner jusqu'à 50000 euros
oui au dinar le grès rose noire il aide
les piles il reste un homme qui reste un
tuba il reste 1 dinar tunisien le dinar
tunisien
que dit la boîte numéro 12
c'est bon
qu'est ce que tu voulais messaoud le
dinar tunisien basse et le tuba
vous avez les mines et tuba [ __ ] mais
williams en dieu merci c'est
exceptionnel camilo laich
c'est un parcours de ouf car un okami
est ce que tu veux éliminer nouvelle
boîte l'a14 ouais là 14 j'en peux plus
c'est trop dur ces jours-ci juste qu'on
emballe les chéris pour l'instant je ne
sais pas ce qu'il ya dans la boîte 14 et
je vous le dis je ne sais pas ce qu'il
ya dans les bois camille lellouche et
messaoud font un parcours exceptionnel
okami surtout ils ont ils ont gardé pour
l'instant les quatre boîtes les plus
importantes
camille oui tu as décidé d'éliminer la
boîte 14 mai
[Musique]
alain juppe le reste en place camille
c'est une boîte avec une somme non je
vois des héros non non 10 0
c'est donc où la boîte à milou la boîte
à 5000 ou la boîte à 10000 ou la boîte à
50 milles
[Musique]
c'est stressant nodingues amis je
rappelle qu'on joue pour les hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france et pour
messaoud
tu vient d'éliminer la boîte 14
il reste des piles 1 9 1 dinar tunisien
milo 5000 euros dix mille euros
[Musique]
tous
dans un instant dans un instant je vous
dirais qu'il ya dans la boîte 14 a tout
de suite souhaité il voter on revient
dans deux minutes
merci d'être avec nous les chéris on est
en direct c'est ce soir chez ba ba
sachez qu'on est dans les bois boîte de
baba les bois boîte de baba il est
exactement 20h05
on est avec camille lellouche qu'on aime
qu'on adore aller voir d'ailleurs la
chanson qu'elle a fait sur le corps d'un
virus qui formidable qui a été vue des
millions de fois déjà et elle joue pour
les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
on peut lui dire merci parce qu'elle
joue expressément et elle a la pression
à fond elle veut leur faire remporter
d'argent possible
voilà l est pas bien elle n'est pas bien
et elle joue également avec messaoud
puisque bien sûr la somme sera partagée
entre les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de
france et messaoud messaoud qui est avec
nous mais ça où tu habites on ne sont
pas riches périès bélisle d'accord bien
entendu à vis de la grande belle villa
blanche isabelle belleville label
il j'adore projet boujard allez on y va
exactement ballack au chaud car on
l'achetait assez d'artistes de même si
la belle même villa blanche
c'est ni lagon et on va ouvrir la boîte
on prend notre sérieux déchiré basque
pour l'aviron nation vous avez fait un
parcours exceptionnel
ouais on a besoin de se détendre aussi
parce qu'on est très tendue je sais que
je ne sais pas ce que dans les boîtes à
part dans celle-là j'ai regardé je vous
le dis il vous reste un oeuf des piles
mais un dinar tunisien est tous là
milo 5000 euros dix mille euros et la
boîte à 50000 oh oui 50 millions
camille lellouche afin parcours
exceptionnel jusqu'à présent avec
messaoud où
vous avez fait franchement vous avez
éliminé toutes les boîtes les plus
pourris et vous avez gardé des capteurs
grosse pomme les cherry dans la boîte
numéro 14
il ya de l'argent
toi tu ne possèdes faire j'ai peur j'ai
plein j'ai très peur une grenade on
condamne tout seul
camille tous les téléspectateurs se
demande ce qu'il y a dans cette boîte
[Musique]
camille
et messaoud oui malheureusement les
chéris non non non je sans supplément
vous avez perdu
la boîte
[ __ ] retard asie
la boîte à 50 millions
j'ai seulement la boîte numéro 14 est et
la boîte à 50000 euros
et pour couronner le tout on a un appel
de notre traders mais les cherry ne s'il
vous plaît il reste encore la boîte à
10000 la boîte à 5 min encore des très
belles stop et à la boîte à 10000 euros
qu'il faut aller les chercher là et à la
boîte à cinq milles 1
on a perdu la boîte à 50 me de médias de
très très belles sommes encore à gagner
je sens qu'elle est chéri ouais nan mais
je vous le dis je suis désolé
franchement je suis désolé j'ai grand
large non non non vous avez fait un
parcours de gouffran l'instant et il
vous reste encore la boîte à 10000 euros
à aller chercher
merci ou plancha est ce que vous avez un
deal à leur proposer bah après ce
cataclysme qui viennent se passer oui je
vous propose de vous racheter votre
boîte pour la modique somme de 2000
euros et un chewing gum
ils vont prendre que le chewing gum 2000
euros ce qui ferait 1000 euros pour
messaoud et 1000 euros pour les hôpitaux
de peindre aux travaux dans la division
merci mais franchement je peux pas
prendre cette responsabilité mais ça où
tu me dis
mais ça il reste encore la boîte à 10000
il reste encore la boîte à 5000 il reste
aussi un ami reste un neuf et des piles
je peux mourir s'ils allaient pilou
l'oeuvre dans la dans la boîte
s'il ya un homme vous pourrez faire
pessah ou lépine dans l'oeuf
aussi nous mais ça outre le jeu 6 3
continue ok il continue et attendait non
merci
messaoud pour votre proposition merci
merzouk sur votre proposition
donc ils ont décidé de continuer si vous
êtes avec nous il est 20 heures 10 on
joue au bois boîte de baba et il ya une
très belle somme encore à gagner encore
dix mille euros 5000 euros gagnés on
vient de perdre et 50000 mais on va
aller chercher les 10000 euros pour les
hôpitaux de paris et pour messaoud qui
partagera la seule à la côte d'ivoire et
ça merdouille merzouki peut pas proposer
une vraie sommes pas pourquoi lauriers
et terrain sera mon truc
comment il ya le maxximo ses 10000 on ne
va pas car acheté 15 millions en mai
lille angers un effort exceptionnel la
regarde il regarde j'ai fait un sans
faute jusque là on peut aller sur un
kite 20000 allez on n'en parle plus ah
bah on ne peut alors ma chérie tu sais
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans les
boîtes je ne sais pas également ce qu'il
ya dans la tête de merzig blanchard il
est parfaitement autonome oui merde
c'est quelqu'un qui a été trader pendant
des années alors
on élimine une nouvelle boîte à l'est il
vous reste cinq boîtes à éliminer ces
maladies sur celle-là je t'en supplie
basique sans la bien tout s'est passé
mais ça revient à l'est mais ça où mais
celle qui régit compact et un doute si
tu en as une dans tata avec celle là
lanuf à l'est la nouvelle à nos fans a
été éliminé il reste 4 e à la 4 l'a15 la
d'islande l'a4 la cavalcade gilles
verdez la cat la boîte numéro 4 j'espère
qu'on va pas perdre les 10000 euros
messaoud vous venez d'éliminer la boîte
à cinq minutes ça avait très bien
démarré et là ça devient plus difficile
mais les chéris vous avez toujours la
boîte à 10000 euros la boîte à 1000
euros
nous avons encore vous avez encore du
très très bon allez on élimine une boîte
on passe tout de suite autre chose on
oublie on oublie ses mauvais souvenirs
allez les chérir et quoi comme numéro 3
15 10 11 3 15 10 11
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans les
boîtes je peux pas vous aider les chiens
à l'e3 15 10 11 vous éliminez les
mineurs par une boîte et si on nous
propose un autre deal où il ya de
l'argent on ne peut pas aller à côté de
regarder reste plus que dix mille bon
alors tu vois donc c'est donc alors on
essaye on élimine une dernière la 3 ok
ok la trois alors là vous allez devoir
choisir encore de bois quand les chiens
donc là on élimine la 3
[Musique]
je ne propose lumineuse me dirait
camille
et messaoud
vous venez d'éliminer la boîte à milo
bon il vous reste toujours la boîte à 10
millions il nous reste trois boîtes
difficile et la boîte à 10000 euros
allez on en élimine encore une je suis
sûr qu'on va faire le bon choix
on va aller chercher cette boîte a dit
milo susurre camille aller messaoud et
camions va aller la chercher ces boîtes
a dit milo c'est parti méretz koala il
reste
la 10 à 11 à 15
[Musique]
allez la rose là on voit
non
c'est la boîte à quesnoy qu'on embrasse
hainaut aller là qu'il faut absolument
qu'on élimine l'oeuf ou les piles à les
lofts ou les piles la voilà on a les
langues allaient le dinar tunisien
oui oui il reste allez il reste encore
les 10000 euros et reste encore des
piles et 1,9 ce cas sont à lézinnes je
veux pas prendre le jeu ne veux pas
prendre le banquier tout de suite ok on
va encore éliminer une boîte hockey
camille et messaoud il vrai cela dit
cela 15 ya prévost restera deux boîtes
auquel a dit cela dit ces journées
normalement est ce que je la supprime ou
simple porte bonheur qu'est ce que tu
dis nous sommes vous avez gardé la 5
pour l'instant vous pourrez peut-être
échanger vos boîtes tout à l'heure moi
je sais parce qu'avant les boîtes les
chiens ce que je sais pour l'instant
c'est qu'il nous reste les 10000 euros
les piles et l'oeuf messaoud
on joue pour toi puisque tu va partager
cette somme avec les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
allez on élimine une nouvelle boîte ce
vendredi ce qui reste là dit cela
l'a10 l'a15 et la vôtre l'a5 ainsi sa
fuite que tu veux éliminer ça que vous
avez choisi depuis la 10 l'a dit c'est
mon chiffre porte-bonheur passé mon truc
d'anniversaire j'arrive même bien parler
là à camiers messaoud à l'est et sur
l'a10 mais j'ai pas tarder à 10
tara doutez pas je suis pas sûr a alors
on dit là 15
moi aussi j'ai un doute sur l'a10 ouais
le quinze local
allez je te suis sur la coche la case je
ne sais pas si on a eu tous les deux sur
la tis alors qu'on allait je prends la
oui je prends la 15 on est limite la
boîte 15 cents subi on est là mais la
voix 15
[Musique]
story 3 en théorie du changement c'est
trop dur
[Musique]
à
c'est horrible et si horrible maintenant
camille laurens sweeck amis lellouche
messaoud et tous les sujets
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
il nous reste trois boîtes et il nous
reste une boîte à 10000 euros il nous
reste un oeuf et il nous reste des piles
oui camille et messaoud
oui j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour vous
puisque vous n'allez pas pouvoir faire
pâques ni paix ça puisque vous perdez
vous perdez logique enfin parlons ça pue
tellement fou mais chéri il vous reste
donc deux boîtes
vous avez choisi la boîte numéro 5
depuis le début où il y à des piles
dedans où il ya des 10000 euros avant il
y a notre charcutier trader merzouk
blanchard qui veut vous faire une
proposition
ok merzouk ont déjà déjà pour commencer
bravo bravo bravo pour le fin on voit
large et de pouvoir oser le renvoi de
8000 de gaudi dont on n'est pas au plus
ici là il appartient par action
les opus obliger l'ati pb banque vous
propose de vous racheter votre boîte ont
bien pour 3000 euros à 300 mille 500
euros chacun jan palach les chéris je
vous le dis il vous propose trois mille
euros
mais dans votre boîte numéro 5 il ya
quatre les 10000 aux mauriciens et s'est
dit là vous avez une chance sur deux
puisqu'il ne reste plus que deux boîtes
à l'est et donc la première chose que la
première chose que j'ai à vous demander
c est ce que vous acceptez ou est-ce que
vous refusez la proposition de mr juppe
blanchard est vide et ce à des coûts
très très belle somme 3000 en hausse à
près de 1500 euros pour les seconds et
1500 euros pour les hôpitaux de paris et
de france ruban vert joue en revanche
c'est beaucoup d'argent les chéris mais
en revanche vous avez une chance sur
deux de gagner web
les dix mis lourdement donc oui vous
allez peut-être vous en vouloir si dans
la boîte numéro 5
il y aurait bien aimé lucho fait que mon
père a commencé c'est toi qui les
donnent bah ouais c'était pas moi on
déchire
vous savez savez que cette saison mais
moi je n'ai pas eu le temps de l'action
c'est moi qui ait de l'argent des boîtes
sur ma vie tu crois que c'est que tu as
comme à droite groupe à savoir je veux
pas savoir je ne veux pas savoir comment
repartir avec des piles j'avais de la
ville quelle honte
ah non ça sert d'autres la libye la
halle et en plus j'ai acheté des pylônes
déjà des jeux c'est pas aller déchiré si
vous nous rejoignez on joue avec camille
lellouche qui représente les hôpitaux de
paris et de poche 5e salon blé messaoud
qui est un téléspectateur
pour l'instant on joue au bois bois qui
vous connaissez le principe ils ont
choisi une boîte depuis le début c'est
la boîte numéro 5 est ce que dans sept
mois le numéro 5 il y a dix mille euros
oui ce qu'il y à des piles et notre
charcutier trader
merzouk blanchard c'est nous les moyens
de leur proposer un deal à 3000 euros
pour leur racheter leur boîte c'est à
dire où vous partez tout de suite avec
3000 euros ou bien vous me dites cyril
non on pense que dans la boîte numéro 5
il y a les 10000 aux lots de petits
canaux de l'onu l'autre numéro pardon
c'est quoi c'est le sa guise et l'eau
dce le cif de 5 et le 10 et le jour mon
anniversaire aussi alors alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait
[Musique]
pour réprimer deux chiffres en tête par
hasard
[Musique]
camille lellouche et messaoud à l'efo et
là on est ici est ce qu'après ça on a
droit de changer la voie inverse au cas
où je vous proposerai peut-être
d'inverser la boîte c'est non mais c'est
dans les cordes
c'est dans mes cordes moi je me dis que
3000 euros c'est beaucoup déjà mille
cinq cent mille 500 mais si on pouvoir
c'est une femme il serait en plastique
c'est ça qui est puis et puis déchiré il
vous reste que deux boîtes à dire vous
avez une chance sur deux de gagner des
millions
3 et 12 auriez fait vous allez jean
pierre winter sur twitter les gens vous
disent courage à vous allez les teams
ils sont pour vous il faut espérer
qu'elle ait dix mille dix mille euros
3000 euros c'est jayan way s'est déjà
mis à rude mais en même temps 10 la
hausse et 5000 euros pour les hôpitaux
donc bah oui sur mille autres choses
avec 5000 au mas déjà avec mitrailleur
moi je la garde contre un coup de gueule
il ya déjà une très belle somme de 3000
euros proposés par merzouk mille 500 et
1500 ça ferait mais vous avez une chance
sur deux de gagner les dix mille euros
[Musique]
joie qu'a dit je sais que même s'ils
avaient encore c'est encore une
proposition il faudrait apprendre
maintenant
ouais ce qui change des tremblements moi
je te suis si tu penses que c'est bon
par contre si c'est dans la 5 j'aurai
l'âge mais bon on parle pas c'est pas à
les québécois je les fais confiance
camille franchement là mais moi je veux
pas de responsabilité à 3000 euros c'est
énorme déjà des noms mais je pense que
500 messages depuis tout messaoud que
c'est pas moi si je peux me permettre
mon chéri je pense que ça doit de
prendre la décision est vrai je suis
d'accord c'est pour ça que me voilà ça à
moi ben ouais c'est agace et tu sens
qu'il est tu peux les valeurs a je crois
les 3000 moi je risque pas de me
pardonner ça au moins deux mètres je le
sens depuis le début il veut prendre les
3000 oh ouais mais bon là mais c'est un
nombre de six c'est sûrement mieux tu
prends les 3000 euros c'est sûr et bien
3000 euros pour kabila luz et les six
enfants
repos les hôpitaux de paris et de france
et lui 500 euros pour messaoud alors
bien sûr bien sûr vous vous demandez
pouces est ce que vous auriez garder la
boîte numéro 5
ouais ouais ouais
nous aurions gardé la boîte numéro 5
alors je vais découvrir avec vous ce
qu'il ya dans la boîte numéro ce les
chéris s'il y avait des 10000 euros
vous auriez peut-être dû tenter d'aller
jusqu'au bout dans la boîte numéro 5 et
les chéris c'est messaoud qui a pris la
décision
c'est messaoud mam était une petite
musique qui enrichit s'il vous plaît
c'est messaoud qui a décidé de repartir
avec 1500 euros pour lui et 1500 euros
pour les hôpitaux de paris et de france
[Musique]
camille lellouche camille je sais que tu
voulais aller au couteau ouais je te
sens tu es tu voulais tenter la boîte
numéro 5
je voulais c'est ton chiffre fétiche le
camille nom me dit passage en supplie
dans la boîte numéro 5
je riais reparti
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya de la rage
surtout que messaoud
messaoud qui a dit qu'il prenait les
3000 euros c'est messaoud qui a pris la
décision prendre les 3000 pas décidé
encore terminé on peut plus revenir en
arrière camille faut plus revenir en
arrière mais j'aime bien jouer qu'ils
avaient des vous avez déjà gagné de très
belles sommes 1500 euros pour vous
messaoudi 1500 euros pour les hôpitaux
de paris et de france votre boîte
c'était la boîte numéro 5 n'ai pas voulu
lui faire confiance jusqu'au bout à la
boîte numéro 5 est bien dans la boîte
numéro 5 et chérie
il y avait des heureusement les chéris
heureusement et
on la boîte numéro 10 il y en a trois
numéros 10 il y avait les 10000 euros
les chéris heureusement heureusement les
séries drapeau très bonne décision 1500
euros pour messaoud et lille 500 euros
pour camille clubs font pas pour calmer
le jeu pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france et pas pour toi bac à
lui car il était mort merci continue ce
que tu fais je te kiffe de ouf l'unart
ci a mis en marche et amis membres et
bien merci pendant qu'on est plus quand
même avoir cette somme et baisse est
grave c'est grâce à toi c'est grâce à
toi ma chérie allez je te fais des gros
gros gros bisous et merci à baisser ou
qui part avec 1500 euros les shérifs